normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
everybody know sound of Freedom it was
awesome it was huge now you've got the
shift which is uh uh December 1st yep
you want to tell us about it this is our
first original this uh mirrors our story
uh we met the we met the filmmaker and
writer in 2017 his name is Brock Heasley
this guy has this most amazing story
when he was a kid his dad was actually a
pawn shop owner gunned down in
California uh ended up living was on
Rescue 911 to tell his story and then
Brock when he was h a missionary he was
his dad was shot again and his dad was
was killed so Brock wrote uh started
writing to deal with um with everything
that that uh he was going through in
life and then he and his wife went
through the worst time where they lost
everything they both lost their jobs on
the same day they Lo they were just
destitute and uh he made this film with
pizza money this short film and then he
said I'm going to take this over to
Angel Studios and see how the angel
Guild likes this short film and they
caught the vision of it five years ago
and uh he's gone through a process of of
uh of creating this film and it has the
score on the film just keeps getting
higher and higher and higher and it gets
better and better better until just what
was it 60 days ago or so they passed the
guild to get into theaters yep wow and
so we went ahead and said all right
we're going forward with December 1st
and they went through the guild a lot of
times meaning they resubmitted this film
they sh they they raised he took a $500
short film made with pizza money built a
uh$ 6.5 million budget brought in Neil
MCD from Banda Brothers uh Sean Aston of
the Rings and from stranger things yes
Liz tabish who plays Mary Magdalene and
the chosen Paris Patel who plays Matthew
and the chosen I mean and then Chris
palaha who's like the biggest star on
Hallmark and he's very very good at the
romance stuff which this is a distopian
romance and he made this film it is it
is a and is going Nationwide first-time
director first time writer for a
film uh and this this is going
Nationwide on December 1st is the writer
the director what's his name again Brock
keasley Heasley h e a s l e y yeah
Heasley what did he shoot the $500 thing
on how did he make that with 500 bucks
bunch of friends and favors um called
them favors from his friends and bought
bought them Pizza yep oh so and he
submitted that to Angel and then they
they caught the vision off of that and
he crowdfunded over time it took him a
while but he crowdfunded and raised six
.5 million and build this film wow but
back when he passed the guild my wife
said she she watched the short and she's
like I don't get it Neil I don't get why
you like this film or why the guild
liked this film and then he got to the
full feature cuz the the original was
you know it was dark it was this retells
the story of job in like a Sci-Fi world
and she just didn't get it then she
watched the the screener after he
finished the film finished shooting it
and and uh and she's like I love this
film and and it's testing extremely well
should we play the trailer yep all right
we got a trailer right here let's uh
let's pull it up and and play it for you
guys you guys ready here we go where's
my wife I shifted
her what do you want with
me this is not my
world I've never been to this Lake
before
never walked its
Shores but I will find my way back and I
will find my way back to my
Molly 5 years ago I was left in this
dark
[Music]
place taken from my
wife the people
here have no hope you still looking for
that wife of yours you're clinging to
scraps of rumors
and then he
[Music]
arrived where's my wife I shifted
her for every choice you make there are
countless other realities where you make
a different Choice you're talking about
parallel Earths imagine having the power
to move people from One reality to the
next to shift
them what do you want with me I can make
you a king imagine everything you have
ever
wanted work for me and get back with the
woman that you love okay we go on a date
and maybe we kiss hopefully he's might
to shift you back to your wife it's a
trick if I choose you that's the last
Choice I'm ever going to
make I would never leave you
alone I've seen a bunch of people like
us out there looking for a little
hope there is nothing that I won't do to
you you can't just shoot the
[Music]
devil there was so much evil and
inhumanity in this world but there is
also Beauty and hope and I will find my
way back to
[Music]
her right on man I just got to say uh
you know I look I like winning winning
the culture wars is fantastic sound of
Freedom was amazing I'm looking forward
to this I'm trying to pull up my local
movie theater to see if I can get
tickets right now go to but angel.com
theift and you can see all the different
showtimes there are right now it's
almost I think we're almost to 2,000
theaters right now the me the Les lesson
I learned from the second time we
watched we watched it before the show
went live is don't talk on your phone
while you're driving that guy if you cat
that one second he flicks his like to
see who it is oncoming traffic I'm glad
we've learned this lesson put it on
silent ignore the thing
the slow so you can get there fast
angel.com slthe shift yeah so when the
guy who came up with this was
resubmitting it to the guild did they
provide him feedback on to shift this I
mean so it's a very collaborative
responsive what happens when you when
you go to the angel Guild and you you
sign up and we actually have a URL for
timcast where you go angel.com timcast
will let you sign up for the guild you
can go there you can become a member of
The Guild and you can start voting on
content and you get complimentary
tickets to every single movie so when
you sign up you get it's already the
guild already gets to watch sound of
Freedom they already get to watch after
death you get to watch tell twins early
and then you're going to get two free
tickets to uh the shift you'll get two
free tickets to the new movie called
Cabrini coming out next year so on but
you're building um and you get you get
to watch the next sound of Freedom far
before anybody else does so so angel.com
uh timcast will will get you to the
guild but with the
shift he submitted to the
guild again and again rough cuts and
there's 100,000 Guild members and so you
get several hundred to a thousand people
watching it then they give you a signal
and it comes out as a score 0 to 100
usually like really to pass you have to
be at at least a 60 on that score it's a
it's a signal of how passionate people
are about your film and like the high
60s or low 70s will put you at like 99%
audience scores on Rotten Tom like sound
of Freedom was a 76 it was a 74 74 74
sounded 99 to 100% on tomatoes it's the
the sound of freedom is the most highest
audience rated Blockbuster of all time
on Rotten Tomatoes for audiences
and but the the shift he went back I
think like 12 different times and just
kept getting the signal I'm off and we
don't tell you why you're off you just
see the number you know you're not there
yet and then you can read all the
comments from everybody and try to go
through the noise and find the signal as
a filmmaker so you we're not going to
tell you what's wrong with your film but
people do provide comments they do
provide comments so that you can try to
sift through the noise and find the
signal as an artist to to say uh this is
what's wrong because sometimes people
give you they say one thing but you as
an artist realize oh what's actually
wrong is something totally different and
you solve their problem in a different
way for instance they'd be like I don't
like that character but you realize that
the audio is not right on that character
scenes exactly or you haven't made him
sympathetic enough something else with
sound of Freedom there was early on
people were saying the movie is too long
but the movie wasn't too long we ended
up cutting where where what the problem
was is it went too deep at the beginning
on the difficulty of the the children
right that it just went too deep and
people couldn't get out at the end and
actually enjoy the Thriller part of the
movie because the heart was so heavy and
so we actually cut down the director cut
down the intro of the film not a lot
when everybody was saying cut the way
the audience would respond to say it
just feels long and so you think oh I'm
going to go cut down the slow Parts not
these parts where everybody's balling
I'm going to go cut down the the
non-emotional parts and but where it
needed to be cut down was just a little
bit in the heavier stuff because they
went too deep and then it felt on
because they were exhausted by the end
yeah and it cut down doesn't just mean
like shorten it means like be more just
tight yeah have a have a critical eye of
what exactly is conveying what you want
I think it's not like you're saying cut
all of your movie it's saying you know
review it it's the same thing with an
editorial piece right you could say
something with 5,000 words but if you
have one line that really conveys the
meaning that's honestly you know much
more powerful yeah and what will blow
your mind with the shift is Liz tabish
performance the the one who plays Mary
Magdalene she she shines in this I've
got a quote here that just came in from
Eric artell who's a major Tik tocker and
he said Elizabeth tabish gives the
performance of her career and if you've
seen the chosen you know she's super
good her depth and vulnerability brought
me to tears and we've seen also with
Eric um sorry with with with Chris
palaha who's the they call him sometimes
the prince of Hallmark that's his normal
world as he does Hallmark movies
everybody who's watching right now who
watches Hallmark knows who Chris palaha
is he's a star and but he's doing
something totally different in this
movie it's a very intense
Thriller but he says it's the
culmination of his career for him
culmination of his career this movie and
he knows how to do romance so well so
him and Liz got this chemistry like to
the point you're just like these two uh
what what did one person say one review
was like you can tell these two people
want to
procreate um it doesn't it doesn't show
anything Shan Aston is unbelievable Neil
MCD in my opinion gives the performance
of his career in this movie he's great
this movie we're having especially women
are telling us that this is the best
movie Angel's done and that is a big
deal when you're thinking about now men
men don't put as high as sound of
Freedom sound of freedom is but women I
think the dude saving children is like
really male power it is is I got text
messages from friends are like can we go
kill some pedophiles after they watch
the movie like like H that's not that's
for law enforcement and for yeah yeah
but that's how they feel they're to the
effect let me with the Patriot right the
Patriot is like people are like yeah
this is a great country I feel good
about this I mean I think men and women
watch film and TV and movies for a
different emotional reaction so
interesting so women love this movie
it's like and and it is selling out all
over the country there's movie theaters
selling out all over the country and
we're up against Napoleon so it's a it's
a hard I heard bad
who's playing Napoleon someone wellknown
actor
oh yeah's amazing but the when you watch
this some some of we one one one person
said after they watched it they're like
with Chris palaha they're like it's like
my brain is like this is a this is like
if Christopher Nolan directed a Hallmark
film yeah it feels like they took the
guy out of office space and like shifted
him into that reality where he's he just
has he kind of looks like uh what's his
name from you can't describe this he's
also the handsome guy on a Marvel movie
he's in Marvel Avengers he's an Avengers
end game yeah but in the credits he's
handsome man thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net